digamos que tenemos una oveja y que
tiene hambre
esta es mi oveja un dibujo rápido de una
oveja que está buscando pasto y camina
hacia donde hay pasto para comer
y en su búsqueda del delicioso pasto
camina 10 kilómetros al este 10
kilómetros al este
y luego da vuelta a la derecha y camina
5 kilómetros al sur 5 km al sur
y luego vuelve a girar a la derecha y
camina 10 kilómetros al oeste 10 km al
oeste
mi pregunta para ustedes es que tanto ha
viajado a la oveja pausa en el vídeo y
traten de encontrar la respuesta que
tanto ha viajado la oveja muy bien
tratemos de resolver esto juntos y esta
pregunta tiene una pequeña trampa porque
depende de cómo interpretes la idea de
que tanto es lo que alguien ha viajado
que podríamos tener dos respuestas
válidas en una respuesta podríamos decir
cuál es la distancia total recorrida
dejen de escribirlo este es un concepto
importante distancia recorrida
y estamos hablando de la longitud total
de su viaje o la distancia total de su
camino así que la distancia total en
esta situación sería 10 km
+ 5 km
+ 10 km que nos da 25 km
eso sería 25 km entonces algunos de
ustedes podrían decir que la oveja
recorrió a 25 km si eso es lo que
obtuviste a lo que calcula este es el
total de la distancia recorrida ahora
algunos de ustedes probablemente dirán
espera un momento la oveja ya estaba
aquí antes y después de su recorrido
terminó aquí al final de su viaje así
que cambió su posición y se movió un
total de 5 kilómetros al sur
de este punto a este punto son 5 km al
sur y no importa lo que hizo durante el
trayecto ni cuál fue su ruta
después de todo terminó 5 km al sur de
donde empezó y esta también es una forma
válida de responder a la pregunta que
tanto ha viajado la oveja y a esa noción
se le llama desplazamiento
desplazamiento y en esta situación el
desplazamiento es 5 kilómetros al sur
pausa en el vídeo cual creen ustedes que
es la diferencia entre hacer referencia
a la distancia recorrida contra el
desplazamiento bueno como lo mencionamos
la distancia que recorre a alguien en un
viaje es la longitud entera de su viaje
es el camino completo y no puede ser
negativo
podrías viajar 0 kilómetros pero si tu
posición cambia este resultado se
incrementaría porque es la longitud
total de tu recorrido
el desplazamiento es el cambio en la
posición y como hay un cambio en la
posición no sólo mencionaremos los 5
kilómetros también diremos en qué
dirección la posición de la oveja cambio
5 kilómetros al sur para terminar
dejenlo escribir esto esta es la
longitud total del trayecto longitud
total del trayecto
mientras que el desplazamiento es el
cambio en la posición
cambio
en la posición
y terminamos